welcome to this video against attraction
vast array India no name okay let's see
I played him once and lost don't really
remember that game okay so Queens gambit
here's the big parting of the ways Black
has yeah maybe like 10 different systems
that you can play this is one of them
the route goes in check Jeff playing
them line that amongst cards and
recently played against aronian I think
I already have played this on the
channel recently more than once probably
there are goes in is some gaining some
popularity on them let's say normal
level it's a very popular opening on on
on the super top level for a while now
yeah one reason is probably that this
Bishop before kind of Queens gambit is a
bit more it is a bit more active let's
say then on some very classical Queens
gambit declined variations like the last
go for example which is like rock solid
but to ever win with black young yeah
the other guy basically has to have
heart attack or something otherwise
you're not going to win on the other
hand you have creature loser very rarely
Adam the Rogozin is a little bit more
fighting he's spending lots of time on
this theoretical moves we should be six
now or a six I don't know those kind of
moves rook da it okay
yeah I can go into I up that that's an
interesting way to play it put the
bishop them this night beehive some some
move or is it not making much sense I
don't know probably probably not making
much sense putting the bishop on a
weight is a bit uncommon normally am
trying to put it on d6 but this is
probably am coming coming next in the
near future yeah what is just going for
this very typical minority attack the
style of the cards Bart variation and
the Queens gambit declined just trading
CNT porn and then roll the beep on up
the board okay so if i play b5 now hmmm
what is he doing taking it c5 is not
possible okay so let's play that it can
never be really bad I think so deciding
on that quickly is probably not a bad
idea okay he might take and play night
age for you to ignite edge form we
should be too and as always have g3 so
what am i doing do I look to see one
question is f way let's do the fbook not
sure that those questions are always
difficult to answer
I was thinking that it makes some sense
to him have the a rook protector the a3
pawn ok I wonder yeah that probably
should should get the Queen back hoping
in the defense yeah he's got some pieces
near my king so have to be circumspect
there mmm I wonder night you won this
may be a move I mean okay it's it's a
question what he's playing now okay that
that I did not really expect but doesn't
mean it is bad ok I'm going to try to or
can you take on edge to stuff like that
it's not that's never going to really
work that said it's not clear that it's
not still playing it Bishop h2
now that can this drilling okay I really
have to stop the session after the video
this drilling is sterile but i already
had it too briefly on the on the video
before that i really hate this kind of
thing I mean who doesn't but especially
I'm especially am sensitive to this kind
of noise ok so I'm going to play here
and then get the Queen to f3 or g4 or
something the night with the poor on
edge form is all nice and good but it's
not helping him with with the tech ok
wants to get the Queen here
okay I should have really taken that
into into account a bit more right
I was it was bad yep allowing allowing
that okay it was stupid didn't really
think of that idea at all that that's
the last kind of idea that black hairs
against my king but it is very valid
quite obviously my dear squeegee five
possibly to try to trade off Queens or
in the h-bond
okay i'm going to try to win this pawn
okay I cannot take it now I can however
regroup the Knight to f4 then trying to
take it
ok on f6 I have I can take g6 so maybe i
can get Luke to be seven yeah I can put
it on b7 now that's not helping that
much I am ok I have to play something
Knight to e5 maybe could be an idea 95
why not pressurizing this c6 pawn and
you cannot move this is seven Bishop SF
7s is hanging then black forfeits due to
disconnection mmm yeah I don't know if
this was what kind of disconnect that
was but it looks pretty grim right what
is he doing 97's 97 is the only move to
kind of keep things together and can I
don't know the compounds to play Queen
g4 here with a pretty big advantage huh
I don't really understand the move
probably just because of f6 yeah okay
maybe also back here now I have a pretty
pretty nice position now yeah I
completely forgot about this or ignored
whatever the idea to hear when I when I
regrouped I probably should think of
regrouping here but I was kind of
tempted to block the c5 square until I
recognized that I have to correct things
there okay
now you Angie six now here mm-hmm Jeff I
think I'm okay I'm doing here to control
age five so that Luke h8 h 5 is not
coming the Knights arm I ok they are
really active here and through p1 yeah
that's actually what the comp I I was
gambling a bit here because I wasn't
totally sure that I have something
against this to be honest it's not a
move that you easily play am in with the
time to time disadvantage on one point
is I cannot do this this is just giving
away in the rook so I have to do another
move the comp gives rook c5 with a very
large edge but hmm i don't really think
i would have played that one I don't
really know what I would have played
ahead I really gambled a bit Jim and
that gets that gets on me now that's
very very large edge rework probably
wouldn't have made it timewise okay i
hope you liked this thanks for watching